ich gebe es auch grund zur freude ist
auch wunderbar regierungsbildung man
kriegt alle posten wieso aber bei den
grünen da gab es richtig knallen gestern
aber so richtig einig sollte gestern
haben die ein schönes event gab im
westhafen in berlin im berliner wedding
schöne location ganz ganz toll man
wollte eigentlich dass am tag vorher
auch schon die quasi die koalition
vorgestellt von die ampel koalition und
da wollte man gestern dann der parteien
den parteimitgliedern und der presse und
der deutschen öffentlichkeit die
minister riege der grünen präsentieren
ja man hat die urabstimmung staaten
können aber dann hat sie wieder die
mitglieder noch der presse und auch den
deutschen sagen können wer minister
werden soll weil es eine richtige
blutgrätsche gab war richtig die alten
geräten wieder aufgeflogen sind da sind
alte rechnungen noch mal beglichen
worden cem özdemir war nicht auf der war
nicht auf der liste drauf und cem
özdemir eigentlich ein experte für
außenpolitik manchmal auch für
innenpolitik zuletzt ihre
verkehrspolitik wird jetzt
landwirtschaftsminister und hat toni
hofreiter anton hofreiter der mann mit
den langen haaren den posten wirklich
glaubten letzter sekunde einfach weil er
sich wein gekeltert und weil er gesagt
hat mir hat das robert habeck vor wochen
versprochen dass ich ins kabinett kommen
dass ich einen ministerposten kriege und
den will ich jetzt und das hat dann aber
dazu geführt der ärzte mir ist ein realo
der herr hofreiter ist ein linker
sperren grätscht ein realo einen linken
raus und muss eine reha muss ein realo
raus wer war noch als realo frei katrin
göring eckardt die verloren durch die
blutgrätsche gehen die linken selber
ihren posten also musste eine andere
linke rein wer kommt rein anne spiegel
vize-ministerpräsidentin aus rheinland
pfalz eine linke grüne und so lief das
gestern und das war wohl
das ist eine spiegel die s14
ministerpräsidentin in rheinland-pfalz
da haben wir eine regierung spd grüne
und die sehr versierte frau linke aber
das hat gesagt alles durcheinander
gemacht ich war ja vor ort und wir
hatten ja die eilmeldung fünf minuten
bevor die veranstaltung der grünen
losging hatten wir die eilmeldung und da
wusste dort war schon um gottes willen
da geht wieder etwas schief also die
haben zuerst ihre kanzlerkandidatur
gründlich vermied mit allen möglichen
haben sie wirklich auch ein absturz
hingelegt und dann stolpern sie die die
ampel an den staat also sie verstolpert
den ampel staat durch einen wirklich
blutigen machtkampf die haben dann eine
veranstaltung gemacht es war
gespenstisch sie haben geredet zu ihren
mitgliedern
thal als sei nichts passiert anton
hofreiter ist da aufgetreten in einem
outfit das eigentlich nur gesagt hat ihr
könnt mich alle mal mit der abgewetzten
jeans wurde wirklich angst hat ist
gleich platz finden die nato war die
einfachen der fahrradfahrer die genau in
der fahrradfahrer stelle wirklich sehr
sehr dünn war schon mit einem pony mit
allen der alba nennte drauf und mit
wirklich großen lederjacke die ich in
den letzten in der letzten zeit
überhaupt
aber ist dann auf die bühne gegangen und
hat für den koalitionsvertrag geworben
als hätte ihnen keiner etwas gibt getan
gut das ist ja ja das ist ganz klar
sagen halt das ist schon wirklich
selbstaufopferung und wirklich
selbstverleugnung und ist dann von der
bühne gegangen hat so eine dusche
gezogen das war wirklich schwer zu
ertragen und inzwischen wenn man zu den
grünen geht möchte man so benjamin
blümchen pflaster mit ihm weil die immer
stolpern und sich jetzt knapp schlagen
und so war das gestern auch wieder man
steht da nie und ist bis schon so weit
so beim fremdschämen robert habeck und
anna lena berger besitzen ganz vorne in
der ersten reihe haben hält die erste
rede kann als letzten kann als erster
wieder weg war hinter den kulissen wurde
dann verhandelt es war wirklich keiner
wollte aufgeben sie standen sich
gegenüber mit dem messer zwischen den
zähnen und annalena baerbock musste die
ganze zeit aushalten weil sie hatte die
letzte rede und sie musste wirklich
anderthalb stunden sitzen und gute miene
zum wirklich bösen und zum blutigen
spiel machen und das bei den grünen
richtig was aufgegangen wieder alte
nähte aufgeladen jetzt nicht im griff
hatte robert habeck das ist ja
gefährlich für die nächsten vier jahre
also wenn dabei der fdp hat man den
eindruck der linda der verteilten die
post im alleingang und hat die zügel
fest in der hand bei der spd hat man den
eindruck auch bei olaf scholz ohnehin
und bei den grünen dafür stehen alles
aus den fingern der berbalk in dem habe
ja und wir waren wirklich hart zu hart
und hat mir schon wie bei the moment
steht da heute macht doch nicht schon
wieder so ein denn vielleicht doch nicht
schon wieder aber unterm strich muss man
einfach feststellen sie können es nicht
sie packen es nicht und sie haben sich
verkrümelt und wenn du so eine partei
hast wenn du diese alten gräben hast
dann kannst du nicht jedem alles
versprechen und dann muss dann kannst du
auch nicht kommen da musst du auch etwas
so woanders hingehen und sie haben sich
schlicht und ergreifend beim kugeln
verknotet jetzt ist alles aufgeplatzt
einfach würde ich mir mit anlauf weekend
vom vom fußball wenden wenn der rasen
nass und dann nimmt der verteidiger
anlauf und schlittert dem anderen von
hinten
die beine und er hat wirklich in anderen
beruf weiter so ein stück vom tor den
ball und die beine weg